your sex life is bad I'm Mallory and
we're gonna take 15 of the hardest
relationship questions that really quiz
number one you and your partner have
been together for a couple of years when
they forget your birthday you wait all
day for them to acknowledge it but by
the next morning they still haven't said
a word would you end their relationship
if I forgot your birthday would you end
the relationship yeah yeah I mean I feel
like you're so busy you'd forget mom I
would never forget yours your birthday's
twelve twelve you literally can't forget
12 12 August 26 27 just kidding you and
your partner haven't really been having
much when you should tend to talk about
it they say that they want to experiment
and ask if you'd be happy to open the
relationship fridge file period which
you interlace yes what would you yeah
what do I said open relationship with
that another on your wedding day you
find out that your partner had an affair
Oh
chopped nuts off will you confront them
about it they swear that it's over and
you believe them never the wedding is
all paid for and your guests have
started to write what you end of it yes
would you the weddings already paid for
yeah you've been with your partner for a
little while when you find out they
cheated in their last relationship it
wasn't that they were unhappy err that
there were problems in the relationship
they just slipped up would you in the
relations
you cheat on me what happens it's on
camera now no one keeps on anyone no I
would not and the relationship 80% said
no the past yeah
number five you find out from somebody
else that your partner has kissed
another person you thought you were have
both happy and there seems to be no
reason for it would you end the
relationship this could happen like
someone like this someone respect first
thing some of it you wouldn't do you
wouldn't do it but someone was so it
would strike no I'd be in major trouble
you find out your partner has been
messaging somebody else
the messages are flirty and you're not
happy with them at all but as far as
you're aware your partner hasn't met up
with a person they're texting would you
end the relationship I mean I would
never do it but I'm saying if I was like
oh I always think about the other person
like they would misinterpret it seemed
intentional then maybe yeah I would
break out oh it's like 50 50 53 yes and
47 though the partner is very flirty I
almost did appropriately so you know
it's their personality all right no does
that seem to any time yes I'm flirty
with a lot of women but not a lot of men
mmm
your sex life is bad not just mediocre
it's difficult you just don't see
compatible oh you just don't seem
compatible in bed at all no matter how
many times you've tried would you end
the relationship
yeah I mean how do you even get to that
point where do you really know you use
like porn and stuff
great you give it a chance I feel like
it's not amazing in the first 10 times
it penta yeah big enough sample to
figure it out okay you're nice after
dating for a couple of weeks you make
plans for your partner to meet your best
friend afterwards your friend pulls you
to one side explains that they don't
like your partner at all
what's your interrelationship with a
friend your we know yeah I feel like I'm
too nice it would probably give the
person so many chances even if they yeah
well we don't have a backbone ya know
85% humanity doesn't have a backbone
your partner always makes fun of you in
front of people in an attempt to make
everybody else laugh you don't really
think of much of it to begin with but as
soon as we zoom becomes a regular
occurrence would you end the
relationship no no does I think we enjoy
each other sometimes well it's always
makes fun of you I always been smiling
you I made fun to be pretty often but
like because it's not like look we don't
really mean it there's like a tinge of
truth in it it's not a change this is
the last line that you and your partner
have been watching a Netflix series
together you find out that they watch
this the only thing we watched
religiously is Westworld yeah that's
coming out and I would never watch that
without you okay
so the question is would you break up no
no no okay thank God I thought I said
yes 92% now so you just finished the
quiz which was awesome and we got to
know a lot about each other what should
they do next click the link in the quiz
click the link in the description down
below thanks for watching
[Music]